hi I'm Matt Welch with nick gillespie
here on ask a libertarian 2012 day to
mark the publication in paperback of the
Declaration of Independence with 80s
we're going to do a lightning facebook
question round here just to kind of
quick in Nick's pulse and get this going
so let's start with Paul Williams Scott
what position do libertarians take on
the death penalty against that the
purpose of the state is to protect
people not to kill people they should
use the least amount of violence
necessary to protect people that's
putting dangerous people in jail not
killing them amen brother Nick mark
Santoro says who will take us the space
why Nick I'm so glad you asked i mean
why mark i'm so glad you asked
libertarians will take you into space no
seriously we are at the cusp of private
space travel thankfully and finally it's
going to be people like Richard Branson
an Elon Musk who are dealing with near
space orbit and they're going to
actually start using tourism and it's
happening already if the government kind
of enables it gets out of the way stops
the monopoly on various aspects of it
we're gonna have finally and long delay
that glorious space future next question
gibril k riley ass what about light
rails gonna ask you what about light
rail mr. Cincinnati okay what about like
now light rail if you believe in public
transit light rail is a terrible deal
it's always way expensive and it never
serves the population that it says it's
going to if you don't believe in public
transportation light rail is the last
thing you'd be investing in my rails
basically been a failure everywhere
where it's been implemented in the past
20 years or so who advocated almost
never take it has been my experience
buses work pretty damn well number for
Nick number four is a Tasos curve of
facebook says is libertarianism and
ideology for the rich oh I don't know
why don't you ask warren buffett and
george soros yes there are rich people
who like libertarianism there are poor
people especially in poorer countries
who value libertarianism they see
reduction of government interference as
the quickest way to get out of poverty
and to build this the kind of well
and survival that the more democratic
capitalistic West has been able to do
over the last couple of centuries so
it's an ideology for anyone who believes
in that set of ideas I don't think it is
disproportionately rich unless you have
a secret gold bullion account that I'm
not currently unaware of the final of
the Facebook round of questions is going
to go to mr. Nicholas B it is from rick
sincere if that is your real name which
of the first 43 American presidents most
closely resembled a libertarian I would
say Grover Cleveland from what I've read
about it he was good on domestic fiscal
fiscal policy and civil rights and he
was pretty good about being
anti-imperialist more power to Andy look
good in a bathing suit more lightning
and less lightning rounds coming up on
ask a libertarian 2012 keep looking at
our website and look for our book dr.
independence at a bookstore website near
you
you